in this video i'm going to answer your
questions about motion design
[Music]
hey my name is cameron with motion
science and i've been a motion designer
for over 20 years
and i get asked a lot of questions so
here's a few of the ones i've been
recently asked i see a lot of grid
backgrounds in your design line grid
dotted grid line grid plus dotted grid
etc can you show me how you create them
and how do you decide which one you will
choose in the next design yeah i do use
a lot of different grids in the
backgrounds of my designs but it really
just depends on what the design is so i
don't move
forward with the design thinking okay
i'm going to put a grid in there it all
depends on what the project is so if the
project requires a grid or some type of
dotted background i'm going to put it in
there the way i do that is i just use a
very simple shape layer like a circle or
a line and i use a repeater and i repeat
that shape once and i typically repeat
it again going the opposite way and
there you have a dotted line or a grid
background how do i do data moshing
i've never done data matching before so
i can't really tell you i do know
there's a pretty cool looking script or
plugin on ae scripts
definitely check it out
the data watching i've seen on
the socials is pretty cool good luck to
you how do you overcome laziness well
i've never really struggled with
laziness because i absolutely love
creating motion design so if you're
feeling lazy
about creating motion design i would
look at like take a deep look at
yourself and say is this really what i
want to do because if you aren't
passionate about
creating then you're not going to want
to create if you are still passionate
about creating and you still find
yourself a little bit lazy maybe set a
schedule for yourself
some type of routine that you can do
daily and maybe you just put in like an
hour or two hours a day just saying like
hey i want to create something
devote that time
in that block and go create what would
your advice be for graduate designers
first and foremost you need real world
experience from what i've seen in the
past when i've hired
graduates recently out of school is they
understand the software and some
principles of design and animation but
they don't like they lack the
the necessary
real world experience so you need to get
that that means you can get an
internship
you can get a paid internship or get a
junior level position
at any company who's willing to give you
a shot the biggest thing is just be
transparent with where you're coming
from
let them know you just recently
graduated you don't have any real world
experience but you're eager to get it do
you often mix practical and digital
methods while working with motion i
don't i stay digital almost 100 of the
time it's pretty rare that i
scan something in
to create an asset or element for a
piece
i find that i can
get pretty much everything i need online
in some type of digital form how do i
get the willpower energy um hustle on to
do a personal project and do it good
again it kind of goes back to the
question i just had previously
which is i
love
creating motion design right it really
like fills me up it jazzes me so i enjoy
that now creating personal projects it's
more about setting aside that time to
create that personal project because we
get a lot of times get wrapped up in
doing client projects so set aside a day
on the weekend or two weeks from now and
say hey i'm going to work on this
personal project
give yourself time there's no reason
that you have to rush through a personal
project
it can take weeks or months
or even years to create a personal
project and that's okay just give it
your give it your all give it the
passion you have behind it and do
something that you really
want to do best way to get inspiration
i love getting inspiration from sites
like behance
pinterest
instagram is great as well
i also like to go look at architecture i
love to travel to different cities
different countries
that's the best way for me just to
really get inspired being around other
cultures is awesome too i look at
magazines i look at books i look at
movies a lot of different places don't
just focus on other motion design
or what other motion designers are doing
really broaden your horizon and look at
all forms of creativity out there how to
deal with imposter syndrome and share
our work on social medias yeah i get
asked this question a lot you just have
to do it you just have to post your work
on a social media channel you don't need
to post them on all the channels maybe
you pick instagram right and post one
piece you're going to be surprised at
the positive feedback you get from
people if you get a hater in there
that's really distant on you all you
have to do is block that person and just
let it go right that's going to happen
every once while but most of people are
going to support you and it's great to
get that that feedback from people
because that's how you get better faster
listening to what other people say about
your work and they give you feedback and
you take that feedback in and you go
back and you rework something or you use
it on your next project listen nobody's
perfect no one is the best we all think
we're great and then we see something
else and we're like well am i really
that good but you know what it's just
about having confidence within yourself
and just doing it just put it out there
show it to the world show the world what
you've got and be proud of it how can i
learn motion graphics at less cost i
mean i'm always going to recommend
courses i'm always going to recommend
motion science courses because we are
the best
but if you can't afford a course
youtube is going to be your best option
the problem with youtube is that you can
learn very specific things
but you don't have a road map for what
you should be learning when it's going
to take you a lot longer
to figure those things out whereas a
course is going to give you a roadmap
and say hey we need to start here we
need to end here and when you do that
you further your progress a lot quicker
but stick with youtube and you should be
okay what's your favorite kind of brief
to work on
my favorite kind of brief to work on
is one that has a lot of creative
strengths i know there's a lot of people
out there who say i want an open-ended
creative brief but ones that are very
limited like you have one image to work
with or three images to work with or one
line of type or
this color in a line of type whatever
that is
that's what makes me get the most
creative and i have to troubleshoot and
say okay how can i make this look cool
and i find that i really push myself in
those instances and a lot of times end
up making something that i'm really
proud of and is very creative why do you
not make youtube tutorials well i do
make youtube tutorials it's youtube.com
motion science and if you're here on
youtube you should be able to see them
how do i get a job in the motion area so
the best way to get a job in motion
design is to
practice practice practice get your
skill set up and then make a demo reel
once you make that demo reel you're
gonna send that reel out to
a potential client
studio agency whoever it is that you
want to work for someone that you are a
match for someone who really inspires
you and that you want to create work for
you send them your demo reel send him a
quick email and say here's who i am
here's a link to my reel
and i would love to work for you you
keep it very short and to the point but
it's all about your demo reel
that's what's going to get you hired how
are you a hello from france
hi france i absolutely love your country
i hope to be back soon is there a way to
3d project an image on a curved object
not just a plane you know as far as i
know
no there's not
in after effects you can take a flat
plane and use a cinema 4d
render engine and you can curve that
plane but you can't project once that's
a curve so your best bet is to move into
cinema 4d light
and create a curved plane in there and
project in fact we have a course that
covers cinema 4d and cinema 4d lite with
camera projection here at motion science
how do you work past a technical hang up
where in a project an unforeseen
circumstance arises that requires hours
of trial and error to solve when you're
on a tight timeline yeah if i'm working
on a project and i know that there's
some technical aspect of it that's going
to be coming up i'm going to be working
ahead of time figuring out how i'm going
to do that now some projects you're
going to work on are going to give you
time for rnd that's the time that you
spend research and developing whatever
it is you're going to be challenged with
if there's not already time
you're gonna still know the scope of the
project right whether it's a few days
whether it's a few weeks
you know what the scope of that project
is so if there's something that's
standing out to you that's gonna look
challenging
i would start on in that on trying to
tackle that as soon as possible you
should never get into a situation where
you're you're given a day and
something's kind of sprung upon you like
hey we need you to create this and you
have no idea how to create it
that's not a good client that's not a
good relationship with you and the
client that's not good communication so
you should always know what's coming up
and you should be able to kind of
balance your time and figure out how
you're going to solve that problem how
to create animation from video three
finishing touches yeah that's a really
cool animation that's actually from the
style craft course so if you haven't
checked out stylecraft yet you
definitely need to check it out so i'll
tell you what that's all the questions i
have for this time i really enjoyed
seeing your questions and answering them
and i look forward to doing this again
very soon if you're looking to upgrade
your design skill set master the art of
style and execute like a pro i have a
course called stylecraft that you can
check out at motionscience.tv
you can also learn more about this
course by clicking the link in the
description below as always thanks for
watching my name is cameron and this is
motion science
[Music]
you